giannis triple-team
for number three the league and I sold
points so I'm gonna have to try to
figure a way to play team ball tonight
unless you have a guy that could draw a
double team like this and make a pass
you need to move the rock so Carlton
wide open the tricks foreigners from
downtown take the lessons from the books
they got close and they would disappoint
it last year they're playing like the
team that had their hearts broken over
the summer so he has to find his rhythm
if his team is going to come back in any
type of way and I mean flames when the
season putting it down 20 years old
originally later on the first-round pick
of a Sacramento no matter what the score
is for this team all right Ali how about
Gary Frank juniors has a touch
and the books come right back this
experiment with Portland is up yes
there's a lot of time but you are in the
West Coast and usually can't take
anything for granted
maybe they have to change the style of
late maybe they have to change their
system of not moving the ball around the
powell was traded to the Lakers done by
draft pick Jerry he always gets the best
he always gets his man he has all the
minute and a half gone by the Blazers
hanging around they were McConnell is
five for seven from three-point land
Lopez with listed at 7 foot focus upon
occasion we take another deeper this
time it is Russell a huge Steve with
Middleton out but even with Middleton he
allows that third score
[Applause]
why is the best of the league that's why
is the MVP closes games plays 48 minutes